one of the most prominent Senate races
this November is incumbent extremists
vile disgusting depraved dilapidated I
might even say that makes sense
Texas Republican Ted Cruz against
Democratic challenger better or or we've
been talking about this one it's a tough
one taking out an incumbent Republican
in Texas is an uphill battle but if you
were able to remove such a toxic and
ridiculous Republican it would be a huge
victory it would be an absolutely
massive victory and what we learned
early this morning is that Ted Cruz is
declining to participate in a town hall
debate with Beto O'Rourke on CNN on
October 18th
they have debated already it didn't go
super well for Ted Cruz although it was
a lot of preaching to the choir like I
don't know that mines were necessarily
changed by that first debate I don't
think that baito did all that well
either he just sounded like a typical
politician could have attacked at
different points yeah it was 50/50 I
don't know if it moved the needle but
Ted Cruz is opting not to participate in
this town hall debate his campaign was
asked why he's not participating in this
one they haven't as of this morning
commented and so what that means is that
Beto or work is going to get a one hour
live townhall with voters on CNN Ted
Cruz simply isn't going to be there now
that may actually help better or work
that might actually make a difference I
will say that Ted Cruz isn't just
avoiding all debate with Beto or Roarke
he already debated with him once there's
another debate scheduled for two days
prior to the Town Hall on October 16th
in San Antonio if Cruz showed up shows
up and as far as we know he is planning
to so there's kind of two major
storylines about why might Ted Cruz
decline an opportunity for national
a-one our national appearance national
media appearance with his opponent the
right is saying Ted Cruz has no reason
to do this many debates he's killing it
in the race there's a new New York Times
poll which says Cruz's up nine against
Beto or Warrick 53 to 44 with 3%
undecided which if you believe this
thing's basically over Ted Cruz is going
to win and be reelected if you believe
that you're up nine you might just say I
don't need to do two debates in a three
day three day span I just don't need to
do that
there's
also a level of possible hypocrisy here
because in 2016 Cruz criticized Trump
for canceling a presidential debate to
raise money for veterans or something
like that remember when Ted Cruz said
this Donald Trump has decided not to
participate in the Fox News debate this
upcoming Monday you were ready to go
John Kasich was ready to go Kasich said
he's not going to go if Trump's not
going and your response to mr. Trump's
decision well Megan it's great to be
with you and and for whatever reason it
seems that the Donald Trump finds you a
very very terrifying person he skipped
the daily aisle what cause you were
going to be moderating and and I guess
he doesn't like when anyone challenges
him you know he was saying just a week
ago that he was eager to get one-on-one
with me well this debate that the field
is narrowed even more and he could have
had a direct debate with me and yet
Donald apparently is ducking he's afraid
of being challenged okay so we've got
Ted Cruz's position on debates we've got
the Republican idea that Cruz doesn't
need to debate because he's up nine do I
think that Cruz is actually up nine
probably not I think Democrats need to
get out in Texas I'm not pretending this
is an easy one Texas hasn't voted for a
Democratic presidential candidate since
76 no Democrat has won statewide office
in Texas since 1994 but the left wants
to believe that the reason Ted Cruz
isn't debating is that the first debate
was such a disaster for him that it did
so much damage that he thinks he's
better off simply not showing up to the
town hall I don't really buy that I
don't really buy that that's why Ted
Cruz isn't showing up yeah I don't think
he's afraid of not knowing what he's
talking about or bado catching him in
any traps that sort of thing I think
he's just afraid of some sort of gaffe
right that's what these people try to
avoid and if you're up by nine points
why do you have to subject yourself to
that possibility so let's explore
whether he's really up nine okay there
are internal polls which we've learned
about from sources inside Ted Cruz's
campaign which say that this is not a
nine-point spread that the possibility
of this race being within the margin of
error is a very real possibility so I
believe that the rial
is probably a combination of the two on
the one hand you do have public polling
showing Ted Cruz way ahead but most of
those public polls are based on what's
called the likely voter model and what
that does is it assesses the likelihood
that a voter is actually going to vote
and it only is a poll of those that the
model determines are likely to vote
young people are underrepresented in
likely voter models because one question
that you're asked in determining your
likelihood of voting is have you voted
before if you're 18 19 20 or 21 and you
were not 18 at the time of the last
election you haven't voted before
therefore you are less likely to vote
according to these likely voter models
the young people are under counted so I
think the Cruz campaign knows this I
think they know that they have internal
polls that show that this is much closer
it doesn't look nearly as good for Cruz
as the nine-point lead that the New York
Times claims that he has there has also
been record high turnout for Democratic
registration in Texas and Democratic
primary turnout the highest in 24 years
so if you do a more nuanced analysis of
the polling data from Texas you look at
new voter registrations you look at
likely voter models and understand how
that probably is hurting better or work
in the polls this actually could be much
closer than 9 points do I think that
better or Roarke is clearly in the lead
no at the best-case scenario is that
it's within the margin of error right
now and I think it's safe to say that if
beta or Roarke does pull this off we're
gonna be seeing a huge blue wave of the
2018 midterms that would mean that
Democrats are taking the Senate and they
had a strong night yeah it wouldn't be
you wouldn't just have better or better
or work defeating Ted Cruz and no other
Democratic wave I think is the point
you're making it's all that these races
are correlated good news is we don't
have to wait that much longer
early voting actually starts Monday
October 22nd you can be damn sure that I
will be reminding you that early voting
starts in just 12 days today's program
is sponsored in part by title title is a
different type of streaming service it
actually cares about the relationship
that exists between the artists and the
fans and politically they value
diversity in music
but their politics actually go beyond
that not only can you play your favorite
classics ad-free you can find new
artists but title has an upcoming
benefit concert on October 23rd this is
their fourth such concert Title X
Brooklyn and the whole goal of it is
criminal justice reform we've talked on
the program about the shortcomings of
the criminal justice system how more
than two-thirds of prisoners serving
life without parole for nonviolent
offenses are African American one in 15
African American men is incarcerated
compared to just one in every 106 white
men all net proceeds from Title X
Brooklyn will support organizations like
the Innocence Project which we are
familiar with on the program as well as
the equal justice initiative reform cut
50 and others the concerts themselves
are great in the past they featured
artists like Stevie Wonder Nicki Minaj
jay-z Jennifer Lopez don't miss the free
live stream of Title X Brooklyn on
October 23rd tune in donate at tidal
calm slash Brooklyn that is tidal calm
forward slash Brooklyn